Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to use NVIDIA’s
new AI to create absolutely magical
time lapse videos that were otherwise
nearly impossible to make. Until now.
Watching a video of a landscape in real time
is a smooth experience, but not as interesting
as seemingly, nothing is happening. Now,
speeding them up creates us a time lapse video,
this is finally interesting, however, then this
happens. Oh yes, we get too much flickering.
This is not for human consumption, that’s for
sure. If only an AI-based algorithm existed that
could somehow take the essence of the changes
in this video, but make it smooth as well.
Now, of course that sounds flat out impossible.
Why? Well, in these time lapse videos, we
experience drastic weather changes within a day,
photos for some days are missing, and even worse,
occlusions might happen. Now, let’s have a
look at a previous method trying to do that.
Hmm. Something is happening here, it is
able to keep the weather conditions stable,
so we get no more flickering. However, do you
see it? Growing is clearly happening, but the
details have been washed out so much that the
most interesting part of the video is now gone.
I am not that hopeful that this is
possible to solve well, but just in case,
let’s have a look at NVIDIA’s new AI and see
what it is made of. This is the input, and,
wow! The new method does an absolutely outstanding
job at keeping the weather conditions stable,
but in the meantime, also showing us
sharp footage of this amazing growth.
Now let’s compare it to the previous method. And,
my goodness, there is no contest
here. So much better. Loving it!
Let’s have a look at another example of this
valley and then, I will show you that this
technique also has some more superpowers.
As expected, the input video has way too
much going on, so now, let’s ask the new
method to boil it down to its essence.
That is absolutely incredible. Look,
smooth and detailed at the same time.
And yes, I promised some
superpowers, so what are those?
This technique can not only stabilize the weather
conditions and create smooth and detailed videos,
but, one, depending on our artistic goals, it even
gives us the tools to control the time of day.
And if we wish to think bigger, we
can also control the time of year.
But all that is nothing compared to my favorite,
so hold on to your papers for trends. If there
are structural changes in a landscape
or a city, for instance, at some point,
this building has been repainted, and
now we can decide to forget about it,
and keep it as if it never even
happened, or we can even decide to
use its new appearance for the entirety of
the year. Even before it was painted. Wow!
And we can also account for growth. This
growth can take place as the video progresses,
or it can be fixed in time.
This is so good, I love it.
And now, time for some interesting
tidbits. This technique is based on
the legendary StyleGAN system, which is
able to synthesize these photorealistic
humans and other things in a
somewhat controllable manner.
Also, I bet the authors had a few conversations
asking each other “how on Earth do we put all
this video information into one stationary
image in the paper”, this concept is a little
harder to convey there, so I am so happy to
be able to show you these videos instead.
And what I also loved is this. Look. Are you
seeing what I am seeing? My goodness. Some
of these datasets have not only a few days
missing here and there, there are often a
series of tens of days missing, or even worse,
and the new AI can still create a smooth video
of the changes as if nothing happened. It
synthesizes what happened in between. And,
there is something that is even worse. Look.
The reality of taking these photos is that the
location of the camera can change over the year,
making this barn appear to be bending upwards.
The new AI is can fix that too. Not a problem
at all. It is absolutely incredible that humans
are able to build AI-based algorithms that are
this capable today. What a time to be alive!
Now, not even this technique is
perfect, you see here that for instance,
the chairs are still moving around.
But have a look at how much progress
has been made just one more paper down
the line. My mind is officially blown.
And, good news! The source code and pre-trained
models are also available, so anyone who has
the available resources and expertise can start
using it right now. And given NVIDIA’s excellent
track record in tech transfer, this might make
an introduction in one of their products soon.
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!